mais pour qui il fait passer auprès des
gosses un poivron un feignant ah je peux
dire qu'il pense gratter pour que
j'apporte des canaux à ses enfants à
Noël salut
si c'est de la bonne qualité
mon beau sapin roi des forêts
que j'aime ta vertu
mon beau sapin
perdu
roi des forêts et tu veux toucher les
boules du sapin
[Musique]
mon beau sapin
vers dur mon beau
sapinder par mon patron mais c'est pas
grave
au massacre des sapins de Noël non au
massacre des sapins de Noël non
allez pauvres les pauvres oh là là c'est
dégueulasse
parce que vous vendez des sapins vous
vendez des cadavres et c'est moi
non plus
vous la mettez du rouge et du bleu ils
étouffent ils arrivent même pas à
respirer c'est pour ça il est
morte
parce que là franchement pour moi tu
avais dit que c'est bien le geste non
mais c'est bien mais là mais là
qui est ridicule
parce que nous sachant quoi la démarche
comme ça tu veux
que là c'est pas c'est pas ça cache j'ai
la nature du fait qu'ils sont poussés
pour ce n'est pas saccagé
ils sont cultivés exprès pour être
coupés par la suite donc ce n'est pas du
saccage c'est bien imité quand même oh
là là le pauvre regardez-moi ça aussi
quand tu vas mourir tu vas voir
non rien de rien non on achète plus de
sapin ni un blanc dis un verre le soleil
vivre ce conifère bon au massacre des
sapins de Noël arrêtez arrêtez pas ça
mais non mais vous êtes fous laissez-le
laissez-le c'est pour non là là
vous avez déjà vu la maman d'un sapin en
train de voir son petit se faire couper
la queue comme ça ça vous plairait vous
ça vous plaît
je peux pas je peux pas non non je peux
pas je peux pas il y a trop de vent je
peux rester là dans c'est mieux moi ça
me fait pas de la publicité aussi pour
mes sapins
ah mais c'est fait pour
Noël
[Musique]
non au massacre des manteaux de fourrure
non au massacre des sapins de Noël non
au massacre des manteaux de fourrure non
au massacre des sapins de soleil
mais vous allez laisser ça laissez ça
une petite boule
non tu crois où là je savais pas moi
c'est pas écrit de succès à toi
ou quoi
as-tu la remet au-dessus de la prise
dans le sac puis la prise dans le sac tu
la remets là-dedans tu la prise dans le
sac c'est toi qui l'a prise dans le sac
tu as de la colle ouais
une toute petite balle quoi
arrête de dire [ __ ] tu dis des gros
mots c'est pas bien pour Noël et si t'as
pas de cadeaux à Noël faudra pas venir
pleurer méchant
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai pas demandé de me faire un
bonhomme de neige alors vous arrêtez un
père Noël
c'est quoi ça Père Noël
en plus
mais arrêtez je vous dis il faut pas
faire ça mais je le fais tout seul je
suis dessinateur moi c'est pas vrai
vas-y fais moins un truc
pour les fêtes quand même c'est plus
c'est plus gai et là tu es en train de
mixer de m'énerver là pour les fêtes là
je te dis que tu écris pas après mes
vitres c'est clair ce que je te dis
t'écris pas d'accord d'accord dessine
alors tu fais rien du tout tu fais rien
d'accord non tu comprends pas ce que je
te dis ici tu te fous de ma gueule ou tu
le fais exprès vous
occupez pas qui c'est qui va me faire un
Père Noël non monsieur je suis un pot je
veux rien du tout un beau père Noël un
bonhomme de neige je ne veux rien du
tout une femme
nuecher
dans la gueule un karcher tout à l'heure
ça va marcher monsieur
[Musique]
merci merci
je vais le faire merci
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa noël c'est l'heure de se réveiller
il travaille toi
[Musique]
c'est nous
les enfants
j'ai peur
est-ce que vous voulez me chanter une
petite chanson
[Musique]
Jacques dormez-vous
tous les jouets tous les jouets
[Musique]
c'est tout c'est fini après c'est fini
allez c'est fini Père Noël au revoir
les enfants
[Musique]